la classe politique très mobilisés mais
très divisée autour du projet de loi
contre le racisme et après les propos de
jean marie le pen reportages et analyses
en direct de l'assemblée nationale
invité du 19/20 rené rémond amnistie ou
non lieu pour les hommes politiques
tribunal correctionnel pour les autres
la faire des fausses factures du sud-est
relance le débat sur l'amnistié
enfin 18 postes frontières bloqué entre
la france et l'allemagne les rentrées
français protestent contre le pacs qui
doit être mise en place en juillet
bonsoir il ne siège pas à l'assemblée
nationale il n'est pas sénateur il n'est
même pas maire d'une commune française
il est simplement parlementaires
européens mais c'est à paris il se fait
remarquer et c'est à l'assemblée
nationale qu israël ravi la vedette à
tous les autres députés un comble son
nom jean-marie le pen sont appelés hier
à la désobéissance civique et ses
menaces à peine voilées ont suscité un
émoi considérable dans la classe
politique qui devait débattre du racisme
aujourd'hui sans lui
forcément il n'est pas député mais qui
ne parle désormais que de lui et c'est
ce qu'il voulait mais revenons projet de
loi et vise cette proposition de loi du
parti communiste comporte en fait deux
innovations essentielles la suppression
possible des droits civiques pour les
auteurs de délits racistes
il ne serait donc plus éligibles un
texte que lé groupe rpr et udf ont
décidé de ne pas voter
reportage et ambiance cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale philippe de seif
qui est patrick flohimont le parlement
se saisit d'une proposition de loi
contre le racisme
et c'est encore jean marie le pen qui en
est la vedette jeu venu spécialement
l'assemblée tenir conférence le
président du front national fait salle
comble quand non loin de là les
communistes auteurs du texte sont
quelque peu délaissé par les médias
cette proposition qui prévoit entre
autres la sphère de 12,3 civic à l'égard
des contrevenants ne semble pas pour
autant effrayer le pen qui apparaît même
ragaillardi si je devais faire là les ai
remerciés à chaque fois que le pouvoir
fait une erreur ou une faute
eh bien je n'aurais pas assez une
conférence de presse c'est en effet ce
qui explique la montée en puissance du
front national merci monsieur rocard
merci monsieur marché c'est vrai que mon
dénonçant clairement le pen
j'ai la moindre il n'y a pas la moindre
hésitation la tue effectivement le texte
montre du doigt le front national ce qui
n'est pas du goût de tous les
socialistes dont certains ne veulent
surtout pas transformer jean marie le
pen en victime
c'est le ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement rejette tout état
d'âme
chaque fois qu'on s'occupe d'eux le pen
on le lui rend service moyennant quoi
vous avez un tas de gens qui
l'opposition ne partage pas du tout cet
avis était unanimement que le texte sera
rejeté même les centristes sont
déterminés à voter contre ce n'est pas
par là les passions qu'on réglera le
problème du racisme
je crois qu'il faut que le gouvernement
s'attaque au problème de fonction des
problèmes d'éducation de logement
d'intégration
je n'ai pas par des méthodes comme celle
là qui sont qui font de la publicité à
monsieur lebel section de faire de la
pub à la côte et communistes aux
paloises et déjà on dénonce les propos
tenus par jean-marie le pen ce que j'ai
entendu hier soir à la télévision
apparaissait tenir réellement de karak
ducrocq trop de caractère fasciste que
le texte proposé par les communistes a
été largement modifié et devrait être
voté dans les prochaines heures sauf
surprise et l'ont rejoint précisément
michel le merlan diack de l'assemblée
nationale est ce que le calme est revenu
michel
oui ça y est la discussion a enfin
commencé mais c'est vrai c'est un débat
houleux h est difficile parce que
d'abord tous les débats sur le racisme
sont toujours des débats passionnés mais
parce que aussi aujourd'hui personne ne
se sent très à l'aise dans ce débat les
communistes ont été naturellement
satisfait que soin de leurs textes qu'on
discute mais ils ne vont pas en
retrouver grand chose à l'arrivée le
gouvernement pas très à l'aise non plus
parce que finalement à travers des
textes techniques pas toujours très bien
dominer ils risquent d'apparaître comme
voulant remettre en cause certaines
libertés par exemple sur le droit de la
presse et surtout de remettre en cause
de l'ensemble de sa concertation avec
l'opposition qui allait vers un certain
consensus contre le racisme opposition
non plus pas très à l'aise car bien sûr
elle est contre ce texte
mais elle veut afficher sa bonne voie sa
bonne foi anti racistes alors et vous
l'avez deviné il ne reste que jean marie
le pen qui paradait cet après midi dans
les couloirs de l'assemblée
etait-il vraiment utile
de lui permettre d'engranger ainsi les
dividendes du 1er mai ne serait ce que
sur le plan de l'audience voilà vous
entendez comme moi la sonnerie c'est
sans doute la suspension de séance ils
se retrouveront les députés ce soir ce
climat plutôt malsain au sein du monde
politique est accentuée par le malaise
que la récente amnistie a suscité les
parlementaires sont si jeunes et qu'ils
ont une fâcheuse tendance à s'écharper
sur une décision qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
beauté un nouvel incident s'est ainsi
produit cet après midi à l'assemblée
et oui messieurs et c'est là sans doute
ou le bas vous blesse il n'y a pas que
le groupe socialiste et qui a voté cette
loi à l'exception des communistes qui
ont voté contre
sur chacun des femmes de cette assemblée
sur chacun aux dépens de cette assemblée
sur chacun des bas de cette assemblée il
ya eu des votes pour
il y a eu il ya eu il y a eu d
abstention volontaire et ce texte ne
serait pas passé si vous aviez su
latitude si vous aviez eu l'attitude que
vous indiquez aujourd'hui et au même
moment d'autres élus bénéficié d'un non
lieu dans la sphère des fausses factures
du sud est de la france tous les hommes
politiques impliqués ont été blanchis
cet après midi non lieu ou amnistie les
élus finiront pas au tribunal il n'en
est pas de même en revanche pour les
autres
neuf personnes devront en effet
comparaître devant le tribunal
correctionnel
ceux là n'ont aucun mandat explication
claire sébastien pots-de-vin fausses
factures le béton au soleil du sud est
de la france avait la couleur de
l'argent sale voilà ce qu avait
découvert la brigade financière en se
penchant sur les comptes de la somme à
eux filiale d'une grosse société
immobilière basée à paris l'inculpation
de son directeur général paul pelletier
avait orienté les enquêteurs à chercher
du côté des élus locaux lesquels
recevait des fausses factures un échange
de l'attribution préférentielle de
marché à des bureaux d'études le
bénéfices ainsi réalisés alimenter les
caisses des partis politiques et des
campagnes électorales
trente six personnes sont inculpées
parmi elles de nombreux maires à droite
udf et rpr sont visés à gauche michel
pezet
dans le collimateur aujourd'hui la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de paris a statué appliquant à la lettre
la loi d'amnistié votée en janvier
dernier elle a accordé un non-lieu à
tous les élus locaux
en revanche gérard monade financier du
ps est aussi huit autres élus ont été
renvoyés devant le tribunal
correctionnel définitive d'aller devant
un tribunal c'est quand même pas
dramatique d'autant que ça nous
permettra à nous de monter le dossier
d'apporter des preuves de faire citer
des témoignages qui démontreront que les
accusations qui nous sont reprochés
enfin l'accusation qui nous est qu'ils
est reproché n'est pas n'est pas réel et
que ce que je reproche auquel doit
denisty à la loi sur le financement
c'est de faire l'amalgamme général ou
des gens qui méritait d'être initié le
son c'est vrai mais ils le sont
accompagnés de gens qui ne méritait pas
est ce qui fait que l'on laissait
apparaître à l'opinion publique
tu es beaucoup d'élus sont des gens qui
ne pensent qu à magouiller ce qui est
absolument faux
notre invité rené rémond politologue et
historien et sage on en a on en a besoin
alors rené rémond ce climat délétère
vous rappelle-t-il d'autres périodes
oui ils rappellent d'autres pays qui
auront voir remonter à la surface de
deux vieux thèmes et notamment le l'idée
que la classe politique est plus ou
moins corrompus guéguerre entre elles
une espèce de solidarité qui l'a fait se
défendre de voeux de l'ours lorsqu'elle
est accusé je vous avais annoncé je
crois que tous les éléments qu'il
explique à d'abord le phénomène le pen
qui embarrasse la classe la classe
politique et le pen en profite et le pen
en profite il yal'affaire d'amnesty et
je crois que la mystique on l'a expliqué
elle se défend très bien elle se
justifie il faut rappeler que en france
les partis politiques sont pauvres
puisque les français n'en ont pas les
moyens de vivre que les campagnes
électorales coûtent coûte cher il
fallait donc recourir à des moyens de
culte dieu merci aux vient de moraliser
grâce à la loi sur le financement des
partis et des campagnes électorales plus
tard et par conséquent on pas un peu
tard effectivement et on passe l'épongé
sur le passé mais je crois que si la
mesure est juste ici et là quand même
été une erreur elle me rappelle par
exemple l'erreur commise à la fin d'un
quatrième république lorsque en
appliquant le code électoral sans sans
artifice la majorité a validé une
douzaine au député poujadiste opinion
n'a pas compris il a le sentiment en
fait d'une injustice alors revenons aux
propos de le pen en a
la désobéissance civique est ce que le
front national ne se mettrait hors la
loi il n'a pas encore sauté le pas et
ses propos sont inquiétants ils sont
même menaçant il dit que se réserve en
quelque sorte le bénéfice de la surprise
et il déclare que ces militants
disciplinés leur attente de recevoir des
ordres et n'a pas dit lesquels tant que
la loi n'est pas votée il a parfaitement
le droit de manifester contre elle
rappelons nous à propos d'autres lois où
les gens sont descendus dans la rue
c'est pas du vent où la loi est votée
qu'on doit à l'observer alors est-ce que
si elle était votée il inviterait
désobéissance civile ce qui me paraît le
plus inquiétant dans les propos de le
pen c'est que on a le sentiment que le
front national prend un tournant c'est
un mutant jusqu'à présent c'était un
rassemblement relativement inoffensif or
maintenant on a le sentiment
l'appel aux consignes et la discipline
déjà le congrès en avaient donné l'idée
qui elle va se muer en un système une
organisation de combat et l'on pourrait
revenir à la violence de l'extrême
droite merci rené rémond le pendant ce
temps en europe de l'est par exemple les
hommes politiques et leurs concitoyens
se sont engagés dans un débat autrement
importante qui porte sur les libertés en
roumanie par exemple
bucarest les contestataires ne désarment
pas pour la onzième journée consécutive
il occupe est encore aujourd'hui la
place de la liberté tout un secteur du
centre ville un secteur déclaré par les
manifestants zones libérées du
communisme les opposants menace de
boycotter les élections
il s'estime et sont victimes de
violences aujourd'hui même la femme du
candidat du parti national paysan a été
agressé reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux philippe easter et marc d'où
ces gens c'est sûr voyous organisés par
quelqu'un et ils ont commencé à agresser
mon entourage a pas frappés ils avaient
d
blessé de même casser tes yeux gonflés
des teams ben perforé
victor ou pas n'était en plein meeting
dans le nord du pays
les agressions de ce genre contre des
représentants de l'opposition se sont
multipliées la semaine dernière nous
sommes au siège du parti paysan son
candidat aux présidentielles par exemple
est une radio a dû se réfugier mardi
dernier à buzau dans un commissariat de
police
dans ces conditions c'est impossible
d'imaginer des élections libres
vous avez menacé de boycotter ces
élections bien entendu s'il a le fait
campagne de violence qui doit cesser
immédiatement continue nous nous avons
l'intention de boycotter les élections
une menace de boycott qui a fait l'objet
lundi dernier d'un communiqué commun des
principaux partis de l'opposition
adressé au gouvernement
autre front pour le pouvoir cette place
de l'université ces manifestants
anticommunistes qui ne semble pas près
de se lasser
hier soir un record ils étaient près de
18000 aux uns comme aux autres
le pouvoir repose jusqu'à maintenant une
fin de non recevoir il ne répond pas aux
manifestants qui l'accusent de les
traiter avec mépris
il refuse également le dialogue exigé
par les partis d'opposition à propos de
la violence et des conditions cette
campagne électorale et pourtant la
contestation semble gagner du terrain à
timisoara c'est la place de l'opéra qui
est occupé
même phénomène à brasov à piatra neamt
un groupe de personnes auraient entamé
une grève de la faim
les manifestants de la place de
l'université du caire est content écoles
à l'est toujours en lituanie le
président landsbergis a demandé cet
après midi une médiation
franco-allemande cette médiation
concerne bien sûr la déclaration
d'indépendance et le dialogue possible
avec moscou un espoir en afrique du sud
avec le début des négociations entre le
gouvernement et le congrès national
africain ces négociations vont commencer
entre le chef de la délégation
gouvernementale le président de clerck
que vous voyez qui a fait part de sa foi
et de sa confiance et nelson mandela qui
a dit les conditions existent pour
résoudre les graves problèmes auxquels
nous sommes désormais confrontés espoir
donc de cohabitation entre les deux
communautés noires et blanches en
afrique du sud
l'isq l'europe des transporteurs
routiers chiante and la frontière franco
allemande depuis hier soir 600 camions
français bloquent en effet 18 postes
frontières pour 24 heures motif une taxe
qui devrait être mise en place en
juillet prochain en allemagne fédérale
les routiers français ne veulent pas en
entendre parler reportage de nos
stations de nancy et strasbourg
commentaire marie est la notice au
barrage aux frontières depuis hier soir
600 transports routiers de l'est bloc 18
postes frontières avec l'allemagne
colère contre une taxe taxe votée par le
parlement allemand et que devront payer
les camionneurs à partir du 1er juillet
cette taxe est élevé en moyenne 160
francs par jour ce matin sur l'autoroute
mais sarrebruck les voitures seul passer
au compte-goutte un blocus franco
français car par exemple les
gouvernement hollandais danois ont
décidé de rembourser cette taxe à leurs
transporteurs
ce n'est pas le cas pour la france même
si le gouvernement français s'est dit
préoccupé par une telle mesure
reste que ce blocus de 24 heures est un
premier avertissement si le problème
n'est pas résolu pour le 1er juillet
jour de l'instauration de la taxe il est
bien évident qu aucun transporteur
étranger elle rentre en allemagne pour
une durée indéterminée
les allemands condamné par bruxelles
rétorque nous transporter theil le péage
sur les autoroutes françaises
en fait cette mesure pose le problème de
l'harmonisation européenne
plus de peur que de mal pour les cèpes
spéléologue belge sauvée si la nuit
dernière voici tout de suite les autres
faits marquants de l'actualité en france
grâce aux images de nos stations
régionales commentaire nathalie
darrigrand 6h ce matin les voilà enfin
les sept spéléologues belle sont
fatigués mais sains et saufs il a fallu
12 heures pour les remonter à la surface
12 heures pour assécher la nappe d'eau
qui les retenait prisonnier à leur
sortie soulagement mais aussi réprimande
selon les sauveteurs ils ont agi comme
des irresponsables
on n'a pas vérifié la sortie hier on se
sent bien jouer entre ces expulsions de
squats heures à paris dans le 11e et 20e
arrondissements
la police a délogé ce matin une
soixantaine de familles elles devraient
être accueillis par la mairie de paris
par ailleurs 50 personnes et 12 enfants
s'apprêtent ici à passer leur quatrième
nuit dehors
depuis 28 jours la télévision n'a plus
de mémoire
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel ina
est paralysé par une grève très dure de
l'ensemble du personnel
au coeur des revendications la
revalorisation des salaires
l'astrolabe rentrer pays après sept mois
d'expédition dans l'antarctique le
bateau et les 12 membres d'équipage sont
arrivés ce matin au havre
au programme toilette de printemps pour
les spécialistes des mers glacées
cela faisait plus de 15 ans que les
habits de lumière n'avait pas peuplé les
arènes du soleil d'or ce matin en
quelques coups de bulldozer ont suffi la
mise à mort d'un symbole affirment les
aficionados
il n'y aura plus de corridas à toulouse
l'a3 toujours plus près de vous c'est
notre vocation grâce à l'accord conclu
entre la datar l'ina et fr3 vous pourrez
si vous êtes enseignant ou si vous êtes
élève et vous êtes nombreux à nous
écouter
vous pourrez c'est une première avoir
accès à nos archives et à nos reportages
nous en parlerons dans un instinct avec
dominique alduy notre directeur général
avec monsieur du port le représentant de
la datar et avec monsieur lucas le
recteur de l'académie de bordeaux en
direct de bordeaux
mais auparavant les précisions de nos
confrères de la station de bordeaux de
muriel d'angoulême et de rennes bio
sanchez pascal sur cette première étape
qui profite à la région aquitaine
imaginez une leçon d'histoire sur les
girondins pendant la révolution
française un coup classique avec des
livres scolaires et un tableau noir
ajouter des images des reportages et le
coût représente alors un tout autre
intérêt quand on a regardé des
reportages après on nous a posé des
questions et comme on a bien retenu à
l'origine de cette expérience fr3
aquitaine et ses vingt mille heures de
télévision régionale diffusée entre 1962
et 1990 les documents qui ont été
restaurées un travail entrepris depuis
trois ans dès septembre cette
vidéothèque sera mise à la disposition
de l'académie de bordeaux grâce à une
convention entre l'éducation nationale
l'ina et fr3 nous avons proposé
l'éducation nationale de faire envoyer
tous les matins en dehors des programmes
défaire 3 et sur une bande cryptée une
heure de documents qui seront ensuite
enregistrées par 370 établissements de
l'éducation nationale dans la région et
ça peut être aussi un complément
pédagogique sur ça peut compléter un
livre ça peut compléter les documents
qu'on peut faire passer ça peut
compléter aussi des séries diapositives
qui éventuellement leur projette
l'expérience sera poursuivie jusqu'en
juin 91 si elle s'avère positive elle
sera étendue à d'autres académies en
liaison avec les 22 stations régionales
de fr3 par dominique alduy je faisais
allusion trailer notre vocation
proximité proximité et mobilité 1 nous
sommes effectivement la chaîne des
régions je crois que
fr3 centre chaque jour un peu plus dans
la vie régionale et aujourd'hui on
franchit un nouveau pas c'est à dire que
fr3 ouvre grâce à l'adaptateur grâce au
souhait très très bien exprimé par
l'académie d'aquitaine maintenant
essaiera va dans les classes ne va pas
dans les classes à n'importe quelle
heure et pour n'importe quel sujet va
dans les classes à la demande des
enseignants et pour que toute la
richesse et toute l'histoire
recueilli par les professionnels de fr3
puisse permettre aux enseignants
d'illustrer d'une autre façon l'histoire
des régions
alors monsieur du port est ce qu'on peut
prévoir une extension aux autres régions
oui on peut prévoir une extension à
d'autres régions pour deux raisons la
première c'est que nous souhaitons
contribuer continuer avec fr3 la
collaboration que nous avons engagées en
aquitaine sur ce sujet d'ailleurs et sur
d'autres sujets la deuxième raison c'est
que l'aménagement du territoire s'est
pas uniquement résoudre les problèmes
des zones des régions qui ont connu des
crises de l'emploi très difficile c'est
aussi apporter les services et des
technologies les plus modernes à
l'ensemble du territoire national dans
les zones rurales comme dans les zones
urbaines à mâcher du khat êtes en direct
de bordeaux où est-ce que cela répond à
une forte attente des enseignants et des
élèves
en effet tout d'abord merci pour ce
magnifique cadeau l'attenté forte en
effet nous sommes assaillis vous moi
mais les enfants en particulier nous
nous sommes assaillis par les images et
voilà que l'occasion nous est donnée la
chance nous est donnée est bien de
permettre à des enfants des collégiens
des lycéens avec leur maître d'exercer
leur jugement sur des images qui sont
suffisamment proches d'eux parce que eh
bien ce sont des images qui traduisent
une vie qui n'est pas morte encore
qu'ils aient déjà qui est encore
inscrite dans la dans le paysage qu'ils
habitent ces enfants vont pouvoir donc
exercer leurs critiques leur jugement
par exemple en recueillant des
témoignages qui viendront compléter tel
document
en faisant parler des gens en leur
parlant
merci rock c'est tout à fait tout à fait
essentiel merci monsieur lucas une autre
information qui intéressent ceux qui
s'apprêtent à passer le bac
regardez fr3 tous les dimanches de 10h à
10h30 avec le magazine play back
magazine vous pourrez révisé justement
votre bac élise vous êtes précieux moi
je vous parlais de rock du bus dassier
si elle bute d'acier vous savez paul
c'est le grand prix du rock français est
très logiquement c'est la mano negra qui
a remporté le trophée cette année devant
les innocents ou les [ __ ] vertes
reportage michel vial pas forcément
facile de désigner un successeur à
bashung indochine dao est cher au noir
désir entre autres meilleur
porte-drapeau du rock français de ces
dix dernières années
c'est le casse-tête auquel s'est livré
ce midi le gratin de la rock critic
réunis dans un restaurant de neuilly un
casse tête qui s'est rapidement
transformée en évidence puisque un seul
tour a suffi à mettre d'accord notre
jury de spécialistes
mano negra à vrai dire le nom était sur
toutes les lèvres avant même le début du
vote de manu chao et ses sept copains
confirme donc s'il en était besoin leur
percée dans l'air du temps et leur
statut acquis à la sueur des tournées de
symbole d'une génération
c'est aussi un groupe qui a toutes les
inspirations
nécessaire et obligatoire qui sont au
début des années 80 de classe par
exemple c'est pas un mouvement de
maisons de disques c'était un mouvement
qui est vraiment descendu de la scène
très c'est bien ils sont descendus de la
scène dans le public
il ya un coût de revient coût de revient
ou l'adolescence et janov quoi qu'ils
disent est que en fait l'adolescence
c'est une manifestation de santé je
crois que l'europe c'est une
manifestation de santé avec la mano
negra avec ce groupe là pensent qu'elle
est plutôt voté pour un groupe
pour moi quoi nous laisser cuire de
consacrer des coûts ils sentent qu'ils
ont déjà riche ne s'est pas la peine
tous les groupes précisément n'ont pas
été récompensés à leur juste valeur et
pour son dixième anniversaire un bus
d'acier des années 80 sera attribué ce
soir un grand oublié de la décennie
téléphone niagara ou rita mitsouko
réponse cette nuit au bus palladium
m
voilà en révisant le bac c'est parfait
du rire du cirque des variétés des
christine bravo et du jazz ce soir là le
programme de l'a350 et vous avec l'info
c'est soir 3 à 22h15 présentée par marc
hautement et tout de suite cela météo
complète de florence klein fin du 19/20
bonsoir à demain
oui
m